the idea cave my father
he told me that there are pictures on
the walls and the subway stations of old
buildings old New York
20 years later after going through
everything school college and all that
stuff I thought I'd be fun to give it a
look and to see what my father was
talking about
it was going to be a short article I was
going to illustrate some stations with
some pictures and tell the stories
but it kind of ran away with me
what I set out to do is make a record of
the appearance of the subway stations in
New York City
I take drawings of the mosaic or fans
designs on the walls which embellish the
stations
I devoted much of my time as I can to
doing it evenings or weekends vacation
time even you know it's all sort of a
consuming project so far I've completed
four volumes on 1 2 3 & 4
my ambition is to take care of all the
lines until all the 190s 196 569
1470 stations have been recorded and
seen
why am i doing it okay
my purpose in doing this study is to
make a record of what we've got I want
to like document when it was done and
who did it so that's what I want to do
that's my focus is to give credit to
those who made it possible
I really started in earnest in 1978 and
I thought I'd get this project finished
wrapped up by the year 2030 which is
only 14 years from now perhaps I have a
theory estimate and that suggests maybe
close to the 2040
I'll be in my 90s then but I can still
see
pleasure doing the job is his payment
I'm committed to it that's all it's my
prayer is my purpose it's my life it's
become my identity so I'd look up to